Celebrated on February 14th,...
...Valentine's Day is a holiday where lovers traditionally express their feelings for each other.
Symbols of modern Valentine's Day include the heart shape and Cupid.
The holiday is named for two martyred Christian saints named Valentine,...
...but only became connected with romantic love in the middle ages with the help of poet Geoffrey Chaucer.
Today, giving chocolate, jewelry or presenting one's love with flowers are all customary gifts for Valentine's Day.
However, the most common present is the exchange of love notes known as Valentines.
Over time, Valentine's Day has been reinvented over and over.
It was roughly in the 1940s when the current card giving tradition began.
Before that time, Valentines were mainly handwritten love notes,...
...as opposed to the mass-produced greeting cards of today.
In the second half of the 20th century,...
...the gift giving trend extended to presents of all kind.
And finally, in the 1980s, the diamond industry started promoting jewelry as an appropriate love token.
Today, it is estimated that approximately one billion Valentine's Day cards are sent worldwide each year,...
...making this day the second largest card sending holiday after Christmas.
85% of those cards are sent by women.